>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, PLEASE
SILENCE YOUR CELL PHONES AND
MOBILE DEVICES AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO
THIS WONDERFUL EVENT.
WELCOME TO THE WORLD LEADERS
FORUM.
WE ARE VERY FORTUNATE TO BE
JOINED BY VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
REPUBLIC OF INDONESIA . I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK COLUMBIA'S EAST
ASIAN INSTITUTE FOR COSPONSORING
THIS EVENT. I WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THE MEMBERS OF
THE INDONESIAN DELEGATION.
THEIR CLOTHING MUCH MORE
INTERESTING THEN US IN THESE
SUITS.
VICE PRESIDENT JUSUF KALLA  IS
A LONG TIME PUBLIC SERVANT.
HE ASSUMED HIS CURRENT OFFICE
IN 2014.
HE IS ALSO AN ACCOMPLISHED
BUSINESSMAN AND TRAINED
ECONOMIST.
THE TOPIC OF HIS SPEECH TODAY,
MIDDLE PATH ISLAM FOR HARMONY
AND PEACE  IS A GREAT INTEREST
TO US ALL.
NEARLY 250 MILLION PEOPLE
SPEAKING MORE THAN 300
LANGUAGES LIVE ON INDONESIA'S
THOUSANDS OF ISLANDS.
IT IS HOME TO ONE OF THE
LARGEST MUSLIM POPULATIONS AND
SOUTHEAST ASIA'S LARGEST
ECONOMY.
COMING AFTER MANY YEARS OF
COLUMBIA RULE AN AUTHORITATIVE
GOVERNMENT, SINCE MAKING THE
TRANSITION THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN
A STABLE AND TOLERANT SOCIETY
WITH FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS, A
SECULAR CONSTITUTION, AND A
LEADER.
AND TO YOU ASIA BASIS --
INDONESIA FACES THE CHALLENGE
OF A PLURALISTIC SOCIETY, WHILE
MANAGING NATIONAL SECURITY
CONCERN.
THE THREAT OF THE ISLAMIC STATE
WITHIN INDONESIA IS REAL.
ALTHOUGH THE POLICE ARE
EFFECTIVE, THERE REMAINS
LINGERING CONCERNS ABOUT ISIS.
INDONESIA HAS RECENTLY SEEN AN
INCREASE IN POLITICAL SUPPORT
AND REPEATER CALLS FOR THE
ADOPTION OF SHARIA LAW.
WHEN THE CHRISTIAN GOVERNOR WAS
FOUND GUILTY OF BLASPHEMY,
MODERATES SAID THE CONVICTION
HAD DAMAGED THE INTEGRITY AND
WAS A SETBACK.
WE HAVE INVITED THE VICE
PRESIDENT HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS
THESE TENSIONS AND A HOST OF
CROSSCUTTING ISSUES FACING HIS
COUNTRY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING HIM
TO THE PODIUM [ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. THE WEATHER IS SO
GOOD HERE.
WE HOPE TO ENJOY THESE GOOD
DAYS HERE IN NEW YORK.
FIRST OF ALL, LET ME SAY I AM
THINKING TO SAY GOOD MORNING,
BUT
-- SOMETIMES THE WORLD IS VERY
NOISY NOW, INCLUDING HERE.
SOMETIMES WE DO NOT UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE SHOULD SAY ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK THIS MORNING.
AS MENTIONED, INDONESIA CONSIST
260 MILLION PEOPLE.
IT IS NUMBER FOUR AFTER THE US,
WE ARE VERY CLOSE IN POPULATION.
WE HAVE SO MANY RACES AND SO
MANY LANGUAGES AND SO MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS. AMERICA IF A
CONTENT -- CONSONANT AND
INDONESIA IS THAT ARCH UP A LEGO
SO WE ARE TRYING TO FIND
DIFFERENT WAYS. WE KNOW THAT WE
ARE SEPARATED BY AN OCEAN, BUT
I SAY WE ARE UNITED BY AN OCEAN.
WE DISCUSSED IN THE UN HOW THE
OCEAN CAN BE USEFUL.
BACK IN HISTORY, INDONESIA WAS
NOT BOUGHT BY FORCE OR MILITARY
ACTION, BY TRADERS.
MOSTLY FREIGHTERS, THEY LIKE TO
MAKE COMPROMISE.
THEY LIKE TO MAKE PEACEFUL
TRANSITIONS COMPARED WITH GOING
BY FORCE. THE SECOND THING THAT
IS DIFFERENT IS INDONESIA IS NOW
DEMOCRATIC, COMPARED WITH MANY
COUNTRIES IN THE MIDDLE EAST
WHO SOMETIMES -- THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE A DIFFERENT WAY TO MANAGE
THE COUNTRY.
OUR OBJECTIVE IS THE SAME AS
YOURS, UNITY AND DIVERSITY. WE
HAVE THE SAME PHILOSOPHY OF HOW
TO MANAGE THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
BESIDE THE HISTORY, DIFFERENT
ISLANDS AND SOMETIMES DIFFERENT
CULTURES, IF YOU SEE MY FRIEND
HERE NO ONE WITH THE SAME COLOR,
ALL DIFFERENT.
BUT WE ARE UNITED.
HOW CAN INDONESIA MANAGE THE
DIFFERENCES? IF YOU SEE
INDONESIAN TOURISTS ARTICLES
THE FIRST THING YOU SEE ARE THE
BODY.
WE ARE MATURELY MUSLIM, BUT THE
MAJORITY ARE HINDU AND BUDDHIST.
WE HAVE TEMPLES OF BUDDHIST AND
BALI, THEY ARE MOSTLY HINDU.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO GO TO THE
HINDU AREA.
I THINK ALL TEMPLES HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED, BUT IT IS OUR ICON
FOR INDONESIA.
BESIDES THAT, NO ONE COUNTRY
LIKE INDONESIA, FORMAL HOLIDAYS
THERE ARE 60 DAYS PER YEAR.
FIVE OF THEM ARE MUSLIM
HOLIDAYS.
THERE ARE THREE CHRISTIAN
HOLIDAYS, TWO BUDDHIST HOLIDAYS
, AND EVEN A CHINESE HOLIDAY.
WE ARE VERY RESPECTIVE OF EACH
OTHER. WE HOPE THAT AN AMERICAN
HOLIDAY WILL BE A FORMAL
HOLIDAY FOR OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE ONE NATIONAL HOLIDAY
FOR BUDDHIST AND INDONESIA.
THAT IS ONE THING, WE RESPECT
EACH OTHER.
IN OUR COVENANT THERE ARE
CERTIFIED MEMBERS FOR INDONESIA.
THEY ALL COME FROM DIFFERENT
AREAS AND DIFFERENT RELIGIONS.
ALL MEMBERS HAVE ONE SEAT IN
THE COVENANT, ALL DIFFERENT
PARTIES, BUT WE HAVE HARMONY.
THIS IS ONE THING, HOW TO
MANAGE?
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES AND MAYBE
YOU HEARD ABOUT THE ELECTIONS.
THE CHINESE COMPETED, BUT THEY
LOST.
THERE WERE NO PROBLEMS.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE PART OF ISLAM BY
HISTORY, BY EDUCATION, AND BY
PRACTICING IN THE COUNTRY.
THE KINGDOM, IT IS OKAY, NO
PROBLEM.
ONE QUESTION MAYBE WHAT KIND OF
REPUBLIC? BUT THE REPUBLIC IS
NEARLY THE SAME WITH THE
KINGDOM.
THE PUBLIC SHOULD HAVE
PARLIAMENTARIAN FOR MANY THINGS
THEY DO, BUT THEY CANNOT DO
THIS.
THAT IS WHY THE FAILURE OF THE
COUNTRY IS COMING.
I THINK THE PROBLEM IS NOW
ISLAM A PHOBIA.
I CAN TELL YOU THERE ARE
DIFFERENT RELIGIONS AND
INDONESIA.
SOME CONFLICT IS IN INDONESIA.
IT IS NOT.
15 YEARS AGO THEY COMPETE
BETWEEN ISLAM AND CHRISTIANS.
THE ROOTS OF THE CONFLICT IS
NOT BECAUSE OF RELIGION, IT IS
ABOUT EQUALITY. IT IS ABOUT
DEMOCRACY.
BEFORE THEY CALLED IT
DEMOCRACY, BUT WITH HARMONY.
THE NUMBER OF MUSLIMS AND
CHRISTIANS IS NEARLY THE SAME,
BUT MANY IMMIGRANTS COME IN AND
THE OPPOSITION IS 55% OF MUSLIMS
AND 45% IS CHRISTIAN.
THERE HAS BEEN CONFLICT. 5000
PEOPLE DIED BECAUSE OF THIS
CONFLICT.
VERY BAD IN OUR HISTORY.
WHAT IS CONFLICT?
NOT BECAUSE OF RELIGION,
BECAUSE OF EQUALITY AND
POLITICS, BECAUSE OF DEMOCRACY.
BEFORE AND INDONESIA LOCAL
PARLIAMENT, BUT WITH NEGOTIATION
AND HARMONY. THE VICE GOVERNOR
SHOULD BE CHRISTIAN IF THE
PRESIDENT IS CHRISTIAN.
IF THE PRESIDENT IS CHRISTIAN
AND THE VICE GOVERNOR IS MUSLIM
THE HARMONY IS THEY ARE.
AFTER OPEN DEMOCRACY
IT HAS EVOLVED.
IT STARTED THE CONDITION OF
WINNER TAKE ALL.
POPULATIONS SHIFT BECAUSE MANY
COME IN AND MANY FORCE THEM TO.
IT IS THE SAME HERE.
THEY FOLLOW YOUR IDEA OF
DEMOCRACY THAT SOMETIMES IT IS
NOT SUITABLE FOR THE CULTURES
OF THE PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT DISCRIMINATION, BUT
THIS HAPPENED BECAUSE OF OPEN
DEMOCRACY THAT WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE COUNTRY. WHY
DID THE DIFFERENT REGIONS COME
IN?
BECAUSE SOME LEADERS ARE USING
THE ISSUE OF RELIGION.
ANY ISSUE OF RELIGION IS VERY
DANGEROUS.
NO ONE IS INDEPENDENT.
CHRISTIANS AND MUSLIMS FIGHT
EACH OTHER.
EVEN WITHIN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
THEY FIGHT BECAUSE OF DIFFERENT
RELIGIONS.
THE ROOT RELIGION IS NOT
CHRISTIAN.
DEMOCRACY SHOULD BE TRANSITIONED
AND THAT DIRECT IT.
WE HAVE LEARNED NOT TO PUSH
COUNTRIES TO DEMOCRACY.
WHAT IS SOMETIMES THE AMERICAN
WAY, IT IS RELIGION HERE.
IF YOU ARE NOT WE SHOULD FORCE
YOU.
DEMOCRACY IS VERY DANGEROUS.
DEMOCRACY HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED
FOR MANY COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD.
THERE IS NO WINNER TAKE ALL.
THERE IS USUALLY A CONFLICT
BECAUSE THE IDEA OF HARMONY IS
WINNER TAKE ALL IN THE
DEMOCRATIC WAY.
THIS HAPPENED IN MANY PLACES IN
THE COUNTRY, BUT AFTER WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE TO
BRING THINGS TO HARMONY.
IF YOU ARE RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR
OR MAYOR IN SOME AREA WHERE THE
RELIGIONS ARE NEARLY THE SAME
NUMBER, GET HARMONY FIRST.
MAKE A PLAN FOR THE ISLAM AND
CHRISTIAN COMBINATION.
DO NOT CHANGE THE SYSTEM ITSELF.
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE WORLD? NOW
MANY PROBLEMS AND RADICALISM'S
INTO HER.
IF YOU ARE A TERRORIST YOU ARE
FIRST RADICAL.
YOU USUALLY BECOME A RADICAL
FIRST AND THEN FROM RADICAL TO
A TERRORIST.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN MANY
COUNTRIES?
WE HAD A VERY SERIOUS
DISCUSSION IN THE UN YESTERDAY
ON HOW TO SOLVE THIS?
WHEN THINGS HAPPEN WHY DO THEY
HAPPEN?
THE FIRST THING THAT I
MENTIONED IS WHY ARE THEY
RADICALIZED?
WHY ARE THEY TURNING TO SUICIDE?
IF THE TERRORIST WHO COMMIT
SUICIDE, WHAT DID THEY EXPECT?
OF COURSE THEY DO NOT EXPECT
MONEY, THEY DIE.
THEY DO NOT EXPECT POLITICAL
OPPOSITION, BECAUSE THEY DIE.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY EXPECT PARADISE,
HEAVEN, IF YOU KILL SOMEONE YOU
ARE GOING TO PARADISE.
WHY DO THEY DO THAT?
BECAUSE THIS GENERATION, THE
COUNTRY IS NOT A PIECE. THE
ECONOMY IS NOT RUNNING.
THEY HAVE NO HOPE.
THEY HAVE NO HOPE BECAUSE THEIR
COUNTRY IS DESTROYED.
THAT IS WHY ALL TERRORIST COME
FROM THE FAILED COUNTRIES.
THEY DO NOT COME FROM ADVANCED
COUNTRIES.
THEY COME FROM FAILED COUNTRIES.
AL QAEDA CAME FROM AFGHANISTAN,
WHO FAILED.
RADICALISM IS THERE BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO SORT THE COUNTRY
AND THERE IS NO HOPE.
THIS DID NOT COME FROM ISIS ,
IT CAME FROM SYRIA AND IRAQ.
THE SAME HAPPENED, A FAILED
COUNTRY.
I ROCK FAILED BECAUSE THERE WAS
NO LEADERSHIP.
WHY NO LEADERSHIP?
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE ARE
DESTROYED.
THERE IS NO HOPE.
THE ECONOMY IS NOT RUN.
THE PEOPLE ARE ANGRY. THE YOUNG
GENERATION IS ANGRY BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NO HOPE.
THE LEADERS OF RELIGION SAY IF
YOU ARE KILLED KILLING YOUR
ENEMY YOU ARE GOING TO PARADISE.
THIS HAS HAPPENED.
THEY SMILE AFTER THEY BRING A
BOMB BECAUSE THEY ARE THINKING
THAT.
WHY ARE THE COUNTRY'S FAILING?
THERE HAS BEEN MORE BOMBING AS
COMPARED TO WORLD WAR II AND
PEOPLE KNOW THEY ARE RADICAL IS
IN TEARS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO SAY WHAT
SHALL WE DO?
THE ONLY DISCUSSION IS WHERE?
WHAT? WHO?
AND WHEN?
THERE WAS NEVER A DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHY? MOSTLY, IF YOU USE
EUROPE THE YOUNG MAN WHO COMMIT
SUICIDE DOES NOT PRACTICE
RELIGION.
IN FRANCE THEY SAY ALCOHOL AND
OTHER THINGS, BUT IT IS A PATH
TO PARADISE THAT THEY ARE
THINKING.
EVERYONE HERE, OF COURSE US ARE
BELIEVING IN PARADISE IN HEAVEN
AND MANY THINGS. THAT IS WHY
WHAT WE DO AND INDONESIA TO
RECOGNIZE HOW TO REDUCE THE
IDEOLOGY.
MORE THAN 10,000 IN JAIL -- 6000
BECAUSE OF RADICALISM AND
POSSIBLY TERRORISM.
THERE ARE SO MANY RADICALISM IN
THE JAIL. JAIL COULD BE
UNIVERSITY FOR TERRORISM.
AND MANY JAILS THEY MAKE THEORY
OF RADICALISM.
IF YOU KNOW ISIS LEADERS,  THEY
ARE RADICAL LIVING IN JAIL IN
IRAQ BY THE US JAIL.
THERE WILL BE MORE RADICALISM
AFTER THAT.
THIS IS A MATTER OF THE WORLD,
HOW TO REDUCE RADICALISM?
IF YOU COMPARE THE PROBLEM IN
IRAQ I THINK IF YOU COMPARE
LIBYA, MOAMMAR QADDAFI OR NO
GOVERNMENT AT ALL.
EVERYONE CAN SHOOT ANYBODY,
THIS IS ONE THING. NOW, THE
PROBLEM AGAIN IS DEMOCRACY WITH
FOURTH IS USELESS.
DEMOCRACY WILL COME BY WELFARE,
BY UNITY OF THE WORLD TO MAKE
OUR PROGRAM, TO REDUCE. THIS IS
ONE THING WE SHOULD UNDERSTAND.
I HOPE THERE IS AN EASY WAY,
INVADING OF COUNTRY ON BEHALF
OF IDEOLOGY IS NOT CORRECT.
YOU CANNOT BUY THEOLOGY BY
FORCE, THE ONLY THING THAT YOU
WILL DO TO CHANGE IS TO STUDY.
YOU DO NOT THAT HE DEMOCRACY
FOR RELIGION.
THIS IS WHAT HAS HAPPENED
EVERYWHERE.
SIMPLY COOPERATE WITH OTHERS.
BUT WHEN WE SEE EACH OTHER WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER'S
IDEOLOGY.
I THINK THE UNIVERSITY IS A
VERY IMPORTANT THING TO TEACH
MORE ABOUT HARMONY. HOW TO
BALANCE THE NEEDS OF LIFE AND
THE NEED OF LIFE.
IF YOU ARE ONLY THINKING ABOUT
AFTERLIFE YOU WILL BE JIHADIST.
IF YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT LIFE
AS WELL AS AFTERLIFE I THINK
YOU WILL HAVE HARMONY IN
BETWEEN.
I HOPE THAT COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY
WILL MAKE A GOOD EXAMPLE ON HOW
TO, BECAUSE YOUR STUDENTS COME
FROM EVERYWHERE IN THE WORLD
AND WILL HAVE UNITY IF THEY ARE
GIVEN A GOOD EXAMPLE OF WHAT TO
DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS.
DO NOT OBEY IN THE COUNTRY WITH
FOURTH. NOTHING WILL HAPPEN
THERE, BECAUSE ONLY
MISCALCULATION
WILL HAPPEN.
NO ONE CAN ANALYZE WHAT NORTH
KOREA WANTS TO DO, BUT
SOMETIMES COUNTRIES ARE VERY
CONFUSED.
THAT'S WHY WE HOPE THE
UNIVERSITY CAN EXPLAIN TO US
WHAT TO DO. IF WE KNOW WHERE WE
ARE GOING TO GO THEN WE CAN GO
TOGETHER AND DO THING IN THE
WORLD.
OF COURSE WE ARE SORRY ABOUT
THE BOMB IN LONDON OR IN PARIS,
BUT IMAGINE 1 MILLION PEOPLE DIE
INFERIOR AND I ROCK, HOW MANY
MILLIONS OF REFUGEES EVERYWHERE
IN THE WORLD BECAUSE OF
UNBELIEVABLE REASONS.
IT IS VERY CONTROVERSIAL.
PLEASE UNDERSTAND WE ARE IN A
COUNTRY THAT IS FAR AWAY FROM
HERE, BUT WE ARE COMMITTED TO
HARMONY LIFE.
NOT JUST WITH INDONESIAN
PEOPLE, WITH ALL PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD.
SOMETIMES EDUCATION IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE A HARMONIOUS
LIFE.
AGAIN, YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I AM ANDREW NATHAN AND I
WILL BE MODERATING THE Q&A.
WHERE THE MICROPHONES THAT
PEOPLE ARE SUPPOSED TO LINE UP
AT?
THERE SHOULD BE MICROPHONES.
HERE THEY COME.
I WOULD ASK YOU TO LINE UP IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ASK A
QUESTION.
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND THE NAME
OF THE SCHOOL YOU ARE IN.
KEEP YOUR QUESTION BRIEF, IF
YOU WOULD.
I WILL JUST START BY THINKING
VICE PRESIDENT KALLA  BOY VERY
SUBSTANTIVE THAT OF REMARK.
GOOD CRITICISMS OF US POLICY
THAT ARE POLITELY STATED AND
HIGHLY PERSUASIVE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I THINK WE MIGHT TRY TO
PERSUADE OUR POLITICAL LEADERS
TO WEAR MORE BATIK. IF I COULD
ASK THE FIRST QUESTION MYSELF:
YOU INDICATED IN YOUR REMARKS
THAT DEMOCRACY SOMETIMES DRIVES
CONFLICT AMONG GROUPS, BECAUSE
IT IS WIN OR TAKE ALL.
LEADERS WILL USE RELIGION TO
MOBILIZE THEIR SUPPORTERS, BUT
YOU ALSO SAID WHEN THERE IS A
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF WELFARE IN
A SOCIETY DEMOCRACY WILL WORK
OKAY.
I THINK I HEARD YOU SAY THAT.
I WANTED TO KNOW WHETHER YOU
THINK DEMOCRACY CAN WORK WELL
AND INDONESIA OR IF YOU FEEL
THAT AT THE PRESENT TIME IT IS
DETRIMENTAL TO INDONESIA?
>> YES.
DEMOCRACY CAN BE PRACTICED IN
INDONESIA, BECAUSE THE CULTURE
AND THE HISTORICAL WAY THAT
INDONESIA IS DIFFERENT, BUT IT
HAS UNITY TO.
-- TOO.
WE ARE IN VERY TRANSITIONAL
CHANGES. IF AN -- INDONESIA
BUDDHIST ARE LESS THAN 1% OF
THE POPULATION.
IT IS THE SAME LIKE INDIA, THE
MAJORITY ARE HINDU, BUT SOME
ARE TAJ MAHAL, THE MUSLIM
IDENTITY.
NOT HINDU, WHY IT DOES NOT WORK
LIKE COUNTRIES IN THE MIDDLE
EAST IS BECAUSE THE HISTORY AND
THE OPPOSITION IS STRIPES.
AND INDONESIA NO ONE'S FAMILY
CAN CONTROL INDONESIA.
IT WILL CHANGE EVERY FIVE YEARS.
BESIDES THAT YOU MENTIONED
DEMOCRACY SHOULD HAVE
TRANSITIONS.
AGAIN MY QUESTION IS WHY WOULD
A COUNTRY BE LED BY A KINGDOM?
DEMOCRACY IS ABOUT EXPRESSING
INDEPENDENCE AND SPEAKING, BUT
LEADERS LOOK AT HIM AS A KING.
THAT IS NOT MATCHING BETWEEN
THE PEOPLE AND THE LEADERS, BUT
INDONESIA, YOU ARE CHOSEN BY
PEOPLE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S GO TO THIS MICROPHONE.
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND YOUR
SCHOOL.
>> I SALAAM ALEICHEM, SIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
HERE AND TALKING ABOUT SUCH
RELEVANT ISSUES.
I AM FROM THE SCHOOL OF
CONTINUING PROFESSIONAL STUDIES.
I AM DOING A MASTERS IN
SUSTAINABILITY MANAGEMENT.
YOU SPOKE ABOUT HARMONY AND
RESPECT AND LIVING TOGETHER IN
PEACE, I WANTED TO KNOW WHAT
YOUR COUNTRY IS DOING FOR THE
GAY AND TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY
TO ENABLE THEM TO LIVE IN PEACE
AND HARMONY?
THANK YOU.
>> THE FIRST THING IS TO DO IT
AND NOT ONLY THING IT.
IF YOU SAY ALL PEOPLE HAVE A
GOOD OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE THERE
IS NO DIFFERENCE, IT IS MUCH
HARMONY. NEW YEAR AND EVERY
HOLIDAY SHOULD BE COMBINATIONS.
HERE I THINK MUSLIM ARE MORE
THAN 1% OF THE POPULATION HERE
IN AMERICA.
THERE IS NO ISLAM HOLIDAY HERE.
WE DO THAT.
WE RESPECT EACH OTHER.
THAT IS HOW YOU CAN HAVE
HARMONY.
>> SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
SEXUAL MINORITIES, THE LGBT
COMMUNITY, THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE
?
>> YOU KNOW, THE FIRST MEANING
OF LGBT WAS IN INDONESIA,
INDONESIA IS 80% OF MUSLIMS AND
MOST RELIGIOUS LEADERS DO NOT
ACCEPT THAT AS A FORMAL LIFE.
SOMETIMES WE KNOW SOMEONE LGBT,
BUT YOU DO NOT ASK PERSONALS.
>> OKAY.
>> HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE WITH US. I AM HERE
ON EXCHANGE SCHOLARSHIP WITH
THE HUMAN RIGHTS EXCHANGE
PROGRAM.
I AM INDONESIAN AND I AM VERY
PROUD.
I AM REALLY AFRAID TO ASK THIS
QUESTION.
EVEN THOUGH I SEE SO MANY
INDONESIANS IT MAKES ME FEEL
INTIMIDATED.
THIS IS A REALLY HARD QUESTION
FOR ME.
I FEEL SADDENED BY THE RECENT
SITUATION AND INDONESIA,
PARTICULARLY IN THE RISE OF
EXTREMIST IN OUR SOCIETY.
IT IS GETTING WORSE NOW AND THE
YOUTH VIOLENCE, HATE SPEECH, AND
THE PROPAGANDA OF COMMUNISM.
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE A SMALL
GROUP, THEY HAVE POWER MORE
THAN THE GOVERNMENT AND THE
POLICE IN MY OPINION.
IN 2013 WE HAD A GROUP
DISCUSSION, ME AND MY FRIENDS
WERE BEATEN. HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
CAME AND BEAT US.
>> I HAVE TO ASK YOU TO KEEP IT
SHORT AND ASK A QUESTION.>>
UNTIL TODAY THEY WERE NEVER
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
MY QUESTION IS WHY IS THE
GOVERNMENT SO WEAK WHEN
CONFRONTING THE ISLAMIC
EXTREMIST? IN TERMS OF DEMOCRAT
AND HARMONY, I DO NOT AGREE.
THAT IS WHAT THEY USE TO ASK US
TO CANCEL THE EVENT.
HAVING A DIFFERENT OPINION MEANS
THREATENING OF HARMONY.
>> WHICH GROUP WHERE YOU
REPRESENTED WHEN YOU WERE
BEATEN?
>> I AM AT THE WOMAN'S GROUP
MOVEMENT.
AT THAT TIME WE DISCUSSED ABOUT
LESBIANISM AND GAY IN ISLAM.
>> THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> HARMONY IS STILL ON THE LOW,
NO ONE IS FREE AT ALL FOR
HARMONY. THE SAME HERE AND
EVERYWHERE.
FOR INSTANCE YOU SAY ABOUT
COMMUNISTS, THEY ARE LOW IN 2000
. LOCAL PARTIES ARE BANNED IN
THE COUNTRY.
IF THERE IS NO THERE IS NO
HARMONY.
THAT IS WHY BECAUSE IT IS VERY
LOW AND IT HAS BEEN VERY LOW
YOU CANNOT BE TALKING ABOUT THE
COMMUNIST PARTY AND HOW THEY
WILL BE IN THE COUNTRY.
THE SECOND THING ABOUT LGBT, IT
IS NOT ONLY IN INDONESIA.
MANY COUNTRIES.
I THINK EVEN IN AMERICA. NOT
ALL STATES CAN AFFORD THAT IN
THE FORMAL WAY.
AS I MENTIONED, THE LGBT
COMMUNITY IS NOT A PROBLEM IN
INDONESIA.
IF YOU GO FORMAL IT IS BANNED
EVERYWHERE.
THAT IS WHY HARMONY MEANS IF
YOU DO SOMETHING IT IS AND
HARMONY.
NOT BECAUSE WE ARE LOYAL TO
HARMONY, BUT WE PREVENT ON
HARMONY.
HARMONY IS NOT BEING THAT YOU
ARE FREE TO DO ANYTHING,
BECAUSE THERE ARE LAWS.>> THANK
YOU.
THERE IS NO ONE AT THIS
MICROPHONE, I AM ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE ON THAT SITE TO LINEUP.
>> HELLO, SALAMA LAKE OF. -- I
SALAAM ALEICHEM.
YOU ARE VERY WELL KNOWN AS ONE
OF THE HEALERS FOR THE PEACE
AGREEMENT IN INDONESIAN
GOVERNMENT, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS WHAT IS
THE SECRET AFTER 50 YEARS OF
CIVIL WAR WITH THE INDONESIA
GOVERNMENT AND THE PEACE
AGREEMENT, WHAT IS THE SECRET
BEHIND IT?
MY SECOND QUESTION IS THAT
LISTENING TO YOUR SPEECH,
INDONESIA IS VERY PEACEFUL
RIGHT NOW.
MY QUESTION IS WHAT MAKES YOU
AWAKE AT NIGHT?
WHAT IS THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
THAT YOU ARE FACING RIGHT NOW
AS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
INDONESIA?
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR
APPRECIATION.
WE HAVE HAD CONFLICT FOR 30
YEARS AND AROUND 20,000 PEOPLE
HAVE DIED.
THERE IS OPPOSITION EVERYWHERE.
THE FIRST THING WE DO IS STUDY
ABOUT THE ROOT OF THE CONFLICT.
MANY SAY THE CONFLICT IS
BECAUSE OF RELIGION.
NO, IT IS BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMY.
PEOPLE ARE THINKING WHY ARE WE
VERY RICH, BUT WE DO NOT ENJOY
NATURAL OIL AND GAS?
FIRST YOU MUST SOLVE THE
PROBLEM OF HOW PEOPLE CAN ENJOY
AND USE NATURAL RESOURCES. THE
NATIONAL LAW SAYS THAT IF 100
PRODUCTIONS 15% GOES INTO THE
PROPERTY ITSELF.
75% OF NATURAL RESOURCES, THE
OTHER SIDE IS IT IS ONE THING
TO USE TO SOLVE THE CONFLICT IS
NO ONE SHOULD BE AT A LOSS.
THERE IS NO SOLUTION.
THAT IS WHY LAST NIGHT I MET
THE PRESIDENT OF COLUMBIA.
BEFORE THEY ASKED ME TO TALK TO
HIM TO EXPLAIN ABOUT HOW TO DO
THE PEACE. I SAID ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS?
YOU CANNOT MAKE A SOLUTION
WITHOUT THE LOSS FACING EACH
OTHER.
THE WAY TO GET A SOLUTION IS
THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM AND NOT
A RELIGION.
THE NATIONAL RESOURCES ARE
THERE FOR THE PEOPLE.
THE SECOND THING IS TO MAKE A
SOLUTION WITH EACH OTHER.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> WHILE WE SEND SO MANY PEOPLE
TO GO OVERSEAS TO STUDY IS
BECAUSE OF POVERTY.
>> THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE, I
AM A MECHANICAL ENGINEERING
MASTER STUDENT.
MY QUESTION IS ABOUT THE
PARENTS-CLIMATE ACCORD AND
INDONESIANS ROLE IN THAT.
BEFORE THE CLIMATE OF COURT
THERE WITH SIMILAR CONCERN THAT
INDONESIA MAY NOT SIGN ON AND
THAT INDONESIA MIGHT NOT HOLD
UP ITS PART OF THE AGREEMENT.
IT LOOKS LIKE INDONESIA IS
MOVING FORWARD ON THAT RIGHT
NOW.
MY QUESTION IS CONSIDERING
INDONESIANS DEDICATION TO
UPHOLDING THE PARENTS CLIMATE
ACCORD, WHAT IS SURE FUTURE
POLICIES ON THE COAL INDUSTRY
AS THAT HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INDUSTRY SECTOR?
>> INDONESIA INTENDS TO
IMPLEMENT THE PARIS ACCORD.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT.
ONE THING IMPORTANT FOR
INDONESIA ARE TROPICAL FORESTS.
INDONESIA IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD WITH A
TROPICAL FOREST OR A RAIN
FOREST, BESIDES BRAZIL.
BEFORE THE 1970S WE HAD 150
MILLION ACRES OF RAIN FOREST IN
INDONESIA, BUT THEN CAME IN BIG
COMPANIES TO TEACH THE PEOPLE
THE FOURTH RELATION -- DIVORCE
RELATION -- TO TEACH THE PEOPLE
FORRESTIZATION.
THEY CUT AROUND 90 MILLION
ACRES OF FOREST.
MANY THINK THERE ARE LANDSLIDES
BECAUSE OF THAT.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE PAYING
ATTENTION TO HOW THE PARIS
ACCORD IF IMPLEMENT IT.
BUT TRUMP HAS SAID THEY DO NOT
AGREE ANYMORE.
IT IS A PITY FOR US BECAUSE FOR
INDONESIA THE TROPICAL FOREST
ARE NOT ONLY FOR THE PEOPLE OF
INDONESIA. HOW ABOUT COAL? 50%
OF ELECTRICITY IN INDONESIA IS
STILL USING COAL FOR PRIMARY
ENERGY.
IT IS THE SAME HERE IN THE US.
COAL IS MOST IMPORTANT. WE NOW
HAVE A POLICY UNTIL 20 YEARS
FROM NOW RENEWABLE ENERGY WILL
BE MUCH IMPLEMENTED, CONSISTING
OF HYDROPOWER OR OTHER
RENEWABLE ENERGY. IT IS A VERY
BIG CAMPAIGN TO DO THAT IN
INDONESIA.
BEIJING IS SOMETIMES VERY CLOUDY
BECAUSE OF THE COAL FACT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I SALAAM ALEICHEM.
I AM A FRESHMAN IN COLUMBIA
COLLEGE.
FOR MANY MUSLIMS AROUND THE
WORLD AND POLITICAL ANALYSTS
ALIKE, THE WAY THAT INDONESIA
HAS BLENDED ISLAM AND POLITICS
IS VERY ADMIRABLE.
HOWEVER, THAT IS NOT THE CASE
FOR OTHER MUSLIM COUNTRIES.
THERE IS A DISCONNECT AND I WAS
WONDERING WHAT DO YOU THINK ARE
THE MOST IMPORTANT FACTORS IN
UNIFYING THE MUSLIM WORLD SO
THAT WE CAN FACE THE COMMON
ISSUES SUCH AS TERRORISM, ISLAM
A PHOBIA, ETC.?
>> AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
DEMOCRACY IS A GOOD SYSTEM, BUT
NOT THE BEST SYSTEM OR WHATEVER
YOU DO.
ESPECIALLY NOT IN THE MIDDLE
EAST.
IT IS NOT EASY TO IMPLEMENT
DEMOCRACY LIKE WHAT YOU DO HERE
IN THE US OR OTHER COUNTRIES.
THE DEMOCRATIC WAY THOUGH S
MAYBE SOMETIMES YOU CAN STUDY
ABOUT RAP DEMOCRACIES OR LIKE
JAPAN, IT IS DIFFERENT.
INDIA IT IS DIFFERENT.
FIRST I THINK LET THE GOVERNMENT
HELP THE COUNTRY TO BE BETTER
UNDERSTANDING AND THOUGHT BEING
A BIG COUNTRY THAT ALWAYS MAKES
PROBLEMS IN MANY COUNTRIES LIKE
IRAQ OR SYRIA OR OTHER COUNTRIES
. LET'S MAKE NEGOTIATIONS.
THAT IS THE IMPORTANCE OF PEACE
. IT IS EASY TO SAY, BUT OF
COURSE YOU NEED HARD WORK TO
MAKE PEACE IN MANY COUNTRIES.
>> WE HAVE TIME FOR JUST ONE
MORE QUESTION.
>> HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS.
IT IS VERY HEARTENING TO HEAR
THE AGREEMENTS THAT INDONESIA
HAVE MADE AN PEACE, HARMONY,
AND DEMOCRACY.
I WAS WONDERING IF YOU COULD,
AND OTHER REGIONAL ISSUES?
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE ROLE OF
INDONESIA IN THE CURRENT NORTH
KOREAN CRISIS?
AND THE SOUTH CHINA SEA IF
THERE PRETTY HOT IN
INTERNATIONAL DISCUSSIONS, WHAT
DO YOU SEE AS THE ROLE IN
INDONESIA AND ASIA AT LARGE IN
RESOLVING CONFLICT?
>> NOT MANY COUNTRIES LIKE
INDONESIA WHO HAVE GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH SOUTH AND
NORTH KOREA.
THAT IS WHY THE PRESIDENT AND
THE DAUGHTERS SOMETIMES GO TO
DISCUSS. WE DO NOT KNOW.
IT IS NOT EASY TO TALK TO THE
PEOPLE IF WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT
THEY WANT.
NO ONE KNOWS PRECISELY WHY THEY
DO THAT. THERE IS GREAT POVERTY
THERE, BUT IF YOU MAKE NUCLEAR
BOMBS I THINK OF LOGIC.
BUT HOW CAN A COUNTRY WHOSE
ECONOMY IS VERY LOW HELP PEOPLE
TO MAKE A ROCKET AND THE OTHER
THINGS? THEY ARE SO EXPENSIVE.
I CANNOT SAY BECAUSE WE DO NOT
KNOW WHAT THEY WANT.
IF I KNOW WHAT YOU WANT THEN WE
DISCUSS WHAT YOU WANT.
THESE ARE THE PROBLEMS THERE.
EVEN THOUGH INDONESIA HAS GOOD
RELATIONS, HOW ABOUT THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA?
YES THERE ARE TENSIONS.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT CHINA
WILL MAKE PROBLEMS IN THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA.
WHY?
CHINA IS AN INDUSTRIAL COUNTRY.
INDUSTRIAL COUNTRIES NEED
TRADING, THEY NEED BUSINESS,
THEY NEED IMPORT-EXPORT.
60% OF EXPORTS IN AMERICA COME
FROM CHINA.
IT IS THROUGH THE SOUTH CHINA
SEA.
IF THERE IS WAR THERE ALL 60%
OF CHINA EXPORTS WILL STOP IN
THE COUNTRY WILL COLLAPSE.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT CHINA WILL
FALL, BUT MAYBE THEY WILL MAKE
YOUR ASSOCIATES RICH AND THEY
CAN MAKE IT WITH THOSE
TERRITORIAL AREAS.
>> MISSED THE VICE PRESIDENT, I
WANT TO THANK YOU -- MISSED TWO
-- MR VICE PRESIDENT, WE HAVE
TO WRAP UP.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR SHARING
YOUR THOUGHTS AND WISDOM WITH
US TODAY AND ANSWERING SOME
TOUGH QUESTIONS.
AT THE UNIVERSITY WE USE
INTELLECTUAL CONFLICT TO TRY TO
WORK OUR WAY TOWARD LONG-TERM
HARMONY.
WE ARE NOT THERE YET, BUT THESE
KINDS OF DISCUSSIONS ARE VERY
VALUABLE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THANKING VICE
PRESIDENT KALLA.
[ APPLAUSE ]